[Music]
Prince Harry and Megan Marco officially
have their royal wedding party confirmed
e.t has learned both Prince George and
Princess Charlotte will be involved as
pageboy and bridesmaid respect to
believe well this comes as no surprise
as Megan really fell for Harry after
meeting his niece and nephew Megan is
very doting with children she's she's
very maternal and she was thrilled to
meet George and Charlotte our royal
expert told ET back in March the
introduction to Prince William and Kate
Middleton's kids were really important
to the redhead royal the reason he
wanted Megan to meet Prince George and
Princess Charlotte was so that she could
see that you know this this will
hopefully be replicated by them that
they would also go on to have children
one step at a time and hopefully will
start a family in their future before
the couple take that big leap into
Parenthood Megan and Harry will take the
first leap saying I do on Saturday
Kensington Palace also announced five
more bridesmaids and three more pageboys
on Wednesday including Megan's best
friend Jessica maroney's three kids who
will be involved in the ceremony
[Music]